here now reaction Fox News contributor
Tammy Bruce Fox and Friends weekend
co-host Pete hey Seth good to see you
both
Tammy we'll start with you the
interesting thing is you know there's
the one issue they want to get rid of
Trump they're willing to lie and and and
do anything and everything to do that
and coordinate even messages with the
Democratic Party
but then they're supporting this in
exchange now I know what there's other
stuff coming out as a relates to see it
end this week because I'm an
investigative reporter is part of being
a talk-show host and my question to you
is this will destroy the country we know
I don't see how America survives the new
Green Deal at 94 trillion and Medicare
for all with no private insurance option
at 36 trillion and that was just the
that's just the estimates well you're
correct and all of the the thing that it
that all these issues have in common is
a disdain for the American people is a
contempt for our ability to understand
our own lives to make our own decisions
to realize what freedom really is that
we can be trusted with freedom that we
are decent people that we in fact make
better decisions than government all of
these decisions socialism is an old dead
tired idea it is nothing new and it has
always failed there has never been
success there's always had to be some
kind of shoring up or some kind of fraud
that goes on when it comes to the nature
of any kind of vague socialism working
we see it of course former Soviet Union
Cuba Venezuela I where ever it's tried
its failed and as a result they're still
addicted to this notion that they are
better than us that they are the ones
who can make the decisions that we can't
that we are too dumb to know that we
can't trust ourselves and so they are
addicted to this notion of being our
superiors to controlling our money and
to proving to themselves as a result
with central planning massive government
taking all of our money ending that the
normal sense of personal freedom because
of course they just don't like us we see
that in the left and their attack on
President Trump he is reviled because
he likes us he likes this country he
wants it to do well that is why he is of
the threat that he is 70 percent top
marginal rate for individuals P 90% for
corporations we're going to add a wealth
tax to that you saved money after they
take 60 cents of every dollar they don't
come back for more and then when you die
they'll take another 40% the death tax
legalized stealing to me and it is going
to destroy this any incentive and then
the numbers don't add it up as I was
pointing out to Tammy yeah I can barely
add anything to what Tammy had to said
say she's absolutely spot on folks
Bernie Sanders is okay no he's he's on
his way out of the presidential campaign
everyone has become Bernie everyone has
become a socialist he's the one that
owns the label so on his way out with
his with his campaign on figurative life
support he's saying I was the real
socialist before the whole Democrat
Party became socialist yet if if
Elizabeth Warren's is not a socialist
than I then I'm an astronaut okay
because everything Elizabeth Warren is
calling for has the hallmarks of social
amiss as she understands that still the
American people understanding their gut
that we are not a collectivist society
where we take from the rich exclusively
to redistribute because that does not
work yet green New Deal Medicare for all
and you made a great point about how how
she's explained to pay for it
she's claims she will not raise taxes on
the middle class yet she's got about the
best message discipline I've ever heard
she says your Medicare costs will go
down but she'll never deny that she'll
raise classes taxes on the middle class
good luck running against President
Trump with the mantra of I'm gonna raise
your taxes to give you government-run
health care after the economy that this
president has delivered she knows that
can't work but in the meantime she's got
a media that won't ask her those tough
questions so yeah and I hope Michael
Bloomberg gets in you know no big gulps
for anybody that's that that would be a
great presidential slopers a nice guy
but I mean I like I don't even drink big
gulps but I like the freedom to buy one
if I wanted one you go to a restaurant I
like the salt on the pig eyes yeah
Elizabeth Warren all of the entire field
the Democrats continue to underestimate
the American people they underestimate
the president also that's why we will
push this away necessarily because they
certainly don't mean well thank you both
for being with us